so this is what I was fighting for years
and years I would I would treat these
extremely complicated patients that you
know we had a reputation for being able
to treat the sickest patients so if you
had multi my my program the team I built
uh at the hospital where was it in Pasad
Los and Cena Hospital okay and if you
had seizure disorder and you were you
know coming off drugs and you had
tuberculosis and you had cancer whatever
it was and you were psychotic we could
handle it no problem um but I would I
would get these the insurances would
call day one to go get the patient out
day one the patient needs I mean
conservatively 3 months of care uh at Le
at least two weeks in a intensive
environment to get them stabilized get
them out and you'd end up talking to a
clerk or or somebody had some clinical
background on the other end going no
doesn't meet our criteria doesn't meet
our criteria get them out of there and
the game was then the patient would call
and complain the insurance company they
go oh Mrs Smith we don't just Dr Pinsky
has to tell us what what it is you need
and we'll be of course we're happy to
cover they don't tell the patient is
they set their own criteria the criteria
are very arbitrary and of no
relationship really with clinical
reality and of course my patient needed
lots of care multi multi system issue
doesn't meet their criteria psychiatric
criteria if I would use medical jargon I
could scare the out of them and
they'd keep them in the hospital even
for minor conditions they go you know I
hear a h holis stolic murmur in the you
know at the Apex and I think they
probably have a corded tener and maybe
some esem keep in the hospital four more
day fine fine fine but if I said they're
they're coming off heroin they're in the
middle of withdrawal they're craving
they've never had a sober day in their
life they're uh a little bit there might
be a depressive disorder there they're a
little bit suicidal but not actively
they'd go yeah yeah send them
home so what's the answer the answer is
I've been through three waves of
so-called parody which is what you were
were saying that there there really not
parody which is exactly
correct it needs to some it's some way
and I don't know how you prevent the
abuses of this but in some fashion the
parody has to be the doctor is of the
opinion that the patient needs three
more days in the hospital whether it is
medical or psychiatric and I work on
both sides of it on the medical side and
the surgical side They Don't Really
argue with us on the psych side Crush
everything just because it's easy you
know there was a there was a document
entry done um not too long ago oh with
we were just talking about this last
night Maya do you know that story no is
that the documentary taking care of Maya
taking care of Maya and she just won her
case uh she just won her case against
the hospital for 220 million but she
John Hopkins yeah she came in with CRPS
I believe diagnosed CRPS which is
explain what what is C you're using it
tell me what CRPS I chronic something
pain Sy
chronic regional pain syr whatever she
was diagnosed by a specialist they
couldn't afford the specialist anymore
they ended up going to the hospital the
hospital didn't know how to um help her
and they ended up thinking that it was
Munch Housen by proxy and they separated
her from her parents then they said that
it was fictitious disease right which is
CRPS sometimes they throw it in there
yeah yeah so then they said she doesn't
actually have it and the whole while I'm
sure they were they were spooling her up
on opiates right well and they went back
and they looked and the hospital was
actually even though they said it wasn't
CRPS um they were charging the insurance
companies for treatment of CRPS it's a
mess yeah it's a mess and that was the
only way they were able to make the
money so it's I don't know if that has
anything to do with what you're well
what I'm saying is that the you know
it's a two-way street the the uh the
medical community M or hospitals or or
Pharmaceuticals want to overcharge
and make money it's for profit and the
insurance company wants to make money by
charging you for this coverage but um I
saw documentary once where they get a um
a stipend for not for being able when
when a a claim comes in yeah for finding
a reason not not yeah it's it's a called
a risk pool they so they hang out as
much as they can and give you as little
access to as much as they can and they
take a certain percentage right off the
top and put it in a bond fund so it's a
mess and I've been fighting my entire
career to try to re first of all they've
adulterated The Physician patient
relationship they've superimposed a
bunch of stuff on top of it what does
that mean they they've made it
impossible for us to to care for
patients I think I just pulled my
headphones out something did you there
we go oh you're good uh and it's I I'm
really at the point where I'm thinking
we have to run up the White Flag we we
lost as doctors we have no control over
the care of our patient we really don't
we have very little control and what
control we had now it turns out 70% of
us are employees so they're listening to
whatever their employer tells them to do
that is not how medicine is practiced
well somehow we have to find a way to so
the the the your most efficient unit is
a properly trained caring physician and
a a informed motivated patient that's it
doesn't get better than that that's your
most effective unit you do anything to
that you're screwing it up you're making
it worse they've completely adulterated
the doctor side with you us working for
insurance companies and hospitals and
it's so ridicul and pharmaceutical
companies as you
mentioned a doctor working for a
hospital is not um motivated by treating
the patient with the best possible care
look they he or she is for sure but look
what happened with Co from on high they
handed down send yeah make them go home
send them home tell them to come back
when they po2 is 80 that was astonishing
to
me